President Trump has promised severe
punishment for seria Raber over the
murder of journalists Jamarcus yaki but
he's also said he doesn't want to put
American jobs or national security at
risk fine although our much vaunted
intelligence partnership with the Saudis
hasn't exactly prevented the total mess
that our involvement in the Middle East
has been for half a century and the
defense industry profiting from arms
sales to revolting regimes like Saudi
Arabia is the single most corrupt and
wasteful corner of the DC swamp but
anyway there's a way for President Trump
to deliver the severe punishment he's
promised without risking our economy or
our security in fact it could make us
all safer since the 70s the Saudis have
been the main funders of radical Islam
based on their own extreme and medieval
interpretation of Islam Wahhabism so
here's an idea mr. president the Saudis
are desperate to get back in your good
books well make them pay for the
privilege
make them pay reparations for their role
in radical Islam make them pay for a new
global network of moderate mosques and
Islamic centers so there's an
alternative to the extremists and the
preachers of hate now that really would
be the art of the deal